je vais appeler denis brogniart parce
que les règles de jeu c'est parce que je
préfère faire
denis brogniart est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci mon dieu limonar que j'aime port
ghalib renard mon chéri d'amour
bon et alors et vous étiez si gilles
aidant c'est super mais j'irai
supercopter excuse moi tu pourras me
vérifier les niveaux aussi de l'hélico
est enlevée où les lettres vous êtes
ridicules pardon il est sexy et qu'il
est arrêté d'être sexy les dégueulasse
alors comment ça va très bien vous êtes
vous êtes tenu de koh lanta la boue on
dirait que travaille dans une friperie
dis-moi frérot cadet jean alors et donc
on sait que vous allez gagner
bah oui face à cet encart parce que nous
on est une vraie équipe rêve est d'être
en quarts des nullité absolue
vous allez mettre voilà le bas sur la
tête
ah bah ça très bien se voir mathieu ça
va super bien
donc ta coupe de cheveux ou encore un
peu plus d'ampleur vous allez essayer de
vous avancez au pub le plus du poteau
mais attend un mois il a déjà biffé
remettre dedans mais sur toi car il faut
bien tenir exactement où bat bien peur
plus avoir à plus bas attention et c'est
le premier qui rira la flamme qui a
gonflé sur la bouche et 2 1
[Applaudissements]
la corde a lancé les siens g8 mettez
donc vous mettez de ce côté mettez de ce
côté chacun veut porter d'autres de la
piscine amoureux de la part des zones
d'efforts devant vous allez tirer que
nous à côté de ça s'arrêtera d'abord
très tôt son énergie ou fort devant moi
sur les mijaurées me gilles et il a de
bons ballons assez cher mais c'est bien
il faut un fort apport
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est pour laisser le sait
beaucoup plus le pauvre il sera mangé
tout savamment gilou oui gilles 26
avaient regardé la tête de gilles verdez
d'empêcher le monde sic au panneau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention avec jean l'attention et vous
vous calmez vous laissez s'il vous plaît
vous laisser faire dans le calme
je veux que cette épreuve se fasse dans
le calcul lui ai pas demandé de s'épiler
ou pas gênant attention on y va les
chèques volés ou tu peux avancer
attention à 2,3 top
[Applaudissements]
et
2 1 c'est quoi est ce que c'est alors
montré passif il assure éric à ces
mortiers le film donc je fais la 12c
gilles nos racines musicales zaïri pour
celle là est la 2 ça va bouger
attention attention à croquer c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur c'est donc celui qui se
rapprochera le plus du centre de la
cible devra prendre la flèche d'un de
ses camarades et la casse et pour
l'éliminer il y aura donc quatre tours
d'ailleurs il y aura que trois tomates
ou gagnera les deux finalistes
les deux finalistes seront soumises à
l'épreuve du conseil denis même dit si
je dis ça ne donne aucune bêtise
rien donc après et tout même les
éliminer pour voter pour celui ou celle
qui partira à las vegas
mathieu l'important c'est d'être le
meilleur attention de sonde à la ligne
mathieu derrière la ligne mathieu armée
viser tirer non pas du tout bénef la
paire par l'achat lâche la
nationalisation attendait marché de
l'art mossé qui moi c'est vrai donc
mathieu qui élimine et vous lasser la
flèche d'eric à la flèche de valérie
bernis mais la flèche de jean michel
maire vous éliminez qui elle prenait la
presse chez vous lirez agressé vous
allez à casser devant la personne
matthieu delormeau il se régale un bien
devant moi vous êtes éliminé plateau ok
attendez attendez d'en bas tandis que
toute lassitude années on pouvait voir
ce n'est qu'un petit morceau on va pas
faire comme dans koh lanta exactement
j'ai assuré nora attendait et n'aura
besoin d'aucun une poule
enora et n'aura rien y'a une poubelle de
verre alors alors attention résidus
alors gilles fitou
[Applaudissements]
attention s'est passé après jean-michel
sont soumis à l'épreuve du conseil
attention attention armées armée je suis
pas prête vas-y viser tirer
[Applaudissements]
mathieu mathieu vous avez gagné
l'épreuve
vous avez la flèche rouge de jean michel
mr la flèche sans couleurs de valérie
benaïm oui vous allez en prendre une
et la casse et est celle que vous ne
passerez pas vous choisirez donc votre
finalistes denis si jean-michel le
bulletin est pour vous vous partez à las
vegas dans l'affluent rêve j'en rêve en
revanche s'il est en saveurs de mathieu
bien tout est encore possible mon cher
mais je serai triste pour mathieu mais
je serais content évidemment de partir
évidemment que je vous demande au cul de
découvrir que jean-michel
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
avon